[Applause]
and finally new rule apple needs to
re-continue to think different about our
privacy apple the company that made it
possible for men to show their women
their dicks from thousands of miles away
is releasing an update that will allow
them to hack into your phone without
your consent to snoop through all your
pictures just in case you're a pedophile
or as matt gates put it i'm switching to
samsung
now let me be clear i'm against
pedophilia that's why i joined cubanon
but nosing through everybody's private
photo stash is casting an awfully wide
intrusive net it's like if the company
that sold you a safe said oh and we're
going to stop by sometimes when you're
not home to make sure you're not keeping
naked pictures of kids in it
our phones should be like our wallets or
purses private
what about probable cause
what about the fourth amendment this is
the very definition of unreasonable
search and seizure which can and will be
abused to find evidence of other illegal
stuff on our phones in my case drugs
now again i think child pornography is
bad and i don't care who knows it
but it's also not a trump card you can
pull out that makes all our other rights
disappear
thank you
and i don't see a very strong fight
brewing against this blatant
constitutional breach and i think it's
because we're so dependent on
smartphones now that we will let them do
anything to us
apple should admit that the problem with
their phones isn't just what people
might store on them it's the phones
themselves
today's phones make people [ __ ] full
stop
and i know whenever someone starts in on
how evil smartphones are there's always
a pat answer coming back about how
people have always freaked out about the
latest technology corrupting young minds
come on they said it about radio and the
telephone and tv
yeah it sounds like that argument might
be right but it's not
it's not none of you think about it for
two seconds
i don't remember lugging a tv under my
cover so i could watch huckleberry hound
until the screen asked me are you still
watching
i looked forward to seeing i dream of
jeannie once a week but it didn't throw
off my circadian rhythm
i liked mikael's navy i wasn't addicted
to it i didn't watch it when i drove
radio to tv was a difference in degree
smartphones are a difference in kind
less like tv or radio more like a
pacemaker
you know something you can't live
without
no other device has ever commanded our
constant attention the way the
smartphone does
of course when i was a teenager i i had
a princess phone
but i didn't stare at it eight hours a
day
[Applause]
there was no hardcore pornography on my
family's 24-inch xena television set
sadly
and we didn't have to worry that maybe
my sister was on the landline with a
strange man who was posing as another
teenager but was really 50.
a former vp at facebook said he felt
tremendous guilt because the short-term
dopamine driven feedback loops that we
have created are destroying how society
works
yet tv didn't do that
psychology today says the average high
school kid
has the same level of anxiety as the
average psychiatric patient in the early
1950s
and that's directly related to social
media
increasingly studies are linking phones
to not just
anxiety but
depression
bullying hate speech fake news sleep
disturbance relationship problems and
photographs of knees on the beach
tv didn't do all that either and tv
didn't turn people into [ __ ]
shady needy passive aggressive mean and
fake
fake outraged fake brave
fake pretty
fake supportive phones make people fake
their lives instead of living their
lives
it's more important to get a picture of
you looking like you're having a good
time than actually having a good time
and the pathetic addiction to likes
did i like my picture of lunch
maybe it wasn't good enough does that
mean i'm not good enough
phones have ruined
self-esteem comedy clubs
concerts
childhood attention span sleep cycles
using toilet time to reflect
and falling off cliffs
oh and dating
which has been reduced from a quest for
true love to looking at a menu
i think i'll have the kelly tonight
phones make people bullies
angrier more vitriolic more racist
online than they would ever dream of
being if they had to say those things to
someone's face
the phone
made us passive-aggressive to our
friends and hyper-aggressive to total
strangers it has two settings i'll kill
you
or you're dead to me
not that if you're dead to me was the
message you wanted to send to someone
you'd even bother sending it because
even texting is too confrontational for
most people now
we don't engage with our friends when we
disagree we just walk away
don't like something delete it don't
want to talk to someone don't reply just
ghost them
ghosting it's the electronic equivalent
of going out for a pack of smokes and
never coming back
cell phones have obliterated courtesy
the fundamental building block of
developing any real relationship
we all see it groups of friends out
together in a car or eating in a
restaurant and they're all staring down
at their phones
imagine how rude that would be if
instead of a phone you brought a
magazine to the table
and read it during dinner with a friend
many is the night i've wanted to say to
someone can you just put the phone down
for a minute after all we haven't seen
each other in weeks and we're having sex
you